beh da tutti i ragazzi che sono video
sono fa vj e dj siamo su the cage man
che sarebbe uomo pacco ed amazon
simulator neurodegenerative setting si
yes
let's go perché come vedete dal menu
cadono scatole a puoi prendere le
scatole che cadono e lanciarle contro
persone ecco le parole che [ __ ] feedap
che sarebbe fede fedex va bene allora
gli animi possiamo partire start non ho
mai giocato sta roba
mi sa molto di prede tutorial certo so
non so cosa fare welcome è impiegato
3.197 davis è stato selezionato per
lavorare la nostra compagnia di delivery
prendi uno di questi pacchetti e il
lancio in sé ma c'e veramente il simbolo
di amazon non sono io che sbaglio bla
mizzon ok dentro il vano a 1 samp ups
sap get into the running e 3d va bene
sono dentro ascolta e importante che
segue york a vacca le miss si chiude la
porta ai porti chiuri a porta la porta
gran papa che gen trovo in due cause
over there
devo prendere un pacchetto è lanciarlo
nella casa ma dove sulla porta va bene
ha quindi potuto lanciarlo anche la sua
ma sto male è bellissimo che voglio fare
il corriere domani inizio si lascia dei
pacchetti a caso faccia bene quello che
tutto quello che devi sapere ora
consegnare solo i pacchetti per
familiarizzarsi con la tua forza ora
cava che va bene
ecco lo cercano neanche centro trova
pieni la tua caffettiera che ha ordinato
sulla sla ma guarda che bravo che sono
sono nato per fare il corriere ecco
infatti come ho detto ma come faccio a
sapere che il patto giusto lei ha
ordinato questo bicchiere tenga perfetto
lei ha ordinato questori parametri venga
grazie storia ai trenta secondi vai vai
tutto dentro cane tutto tutto tutto
porca vacca tutto che rimbalza fuori uno
andato sopra il camion a dhl
hdl tutto dentro tutto dentro la c'è poi
dove riempire il più possibile madonna
che mira brutta ma non puoi re 36 ma non
riesca ad ajka 7 mar al centro e camion
se riesco perché c'è tra i camion non
abbiamo sto male che schifo faccio sono
proprio consegnare non a riempire i
camion sono più quelli che riescono il
collegamento vabbè due pacchi in croce
ho messo cinque pacchi dentro faccio
schifo lei scrive v1 va bene due dei tre
mamma mia che bravo me la puntata perché
ho sfondato la finestra porco demonio
quest'anno ma raccontata pieni ma vaffan
tua sorella vai a prendere parola prende
poco prendilo volteggia il parco in aria
possibile set aspetta aspetta aspetta no
volevo consegnarglielo 12
secondo me sì se vado qua e gli sbatte
sul soffitto faccio prima perché non le
scriveva centrale ma neanche per sbaglio
il camion cioè di mi ritornano tutti
indietro tutte porca vacca quanto
difficile spetta stai fermo ok dai
normale stavolta normale un po ne ho
presi in avrò presi così una decina che
rispetto a prima è un record
elvio veri prima vedere madonna 6 più 4
10 miglia sono fenomeno su anche contare
l'avreste mai detto serve contare per
fare consegnatore di pacchi 12 questi
sono le caffettiere coordinato signora
questo il tappetino
questa è questo il pacemaker perfetto
questa è questa ora cavalca pur in
pendenza questa la finestra nuova park
questa è una porta nuova niente non esca
anche a beccare reporter finale dove non
sfondo vi nulla che mira a brufa poi da
notte cos'è cos'è cos'è cos'è
ma c'è una pianura sopra la pianura ma
come tenga la sua finestra nuova signora
maledizione per lo prendo con lo
prendevo lo dovrei ch dove e dove è
caduto rifacciamo no male ma devi morire
vabbè quanti ne ho presi stavolta più
intenso sempre 10 trovi contare 699 va
bene
e ora la finestra nuova eco a lei
impacchettata perfetto questo per il
gatto questo aperto cugino lei aveva
amazon prime
lei ha vinto per questa era difficile da
marcare amico porca vacca che fenomeno
guardali che fattorino che fattorino
fattorino j
maledizione l'ho presa come arrivato
l'altro pacco le chi ha lanciato quello
arrivato un pacco a caso va bene gli
alberi ve le donne degli orpelli che
sono bravissimo sto gioco 2.500 ex core
penso che più di così non farò mai più
che carino sto gioco mi piace trovare il
modo di centrare il camion e voce preso
la mano e vorrei un fenomeno o solo 30
secondi per centrali cambiano non è male
quello che sto facendo
duro allenamento mi sveglio tutte le
mattine alle sei per giocherà sta roba e
allenarmi da lì a a no no ok bruno al
perfetto
stavolta non presi un botto
probabilmente un botto stavolta tipo 13
6 12 12 va bene va bene va bene record
del mondo stavolta occhio allora 1
ok 2 che è maledizione non so quanto sto
facendo di punteggio ok non male non
male
va bene che scossa veniva se riesco a
fare una roba che sono fenomeno ma
domani voglio che i pacchi me li
consegnano così anche pretendo o demonio
questo l'ho sbagliato
no stavo anche rallentando capirla forse
le scafo ancora in tempo e non capisco
se quando cadde posso fare in tempo a
prenderlo prova prova dai no ero pure
fermo friday last days va bene l'ultimo
giorno a secondo me sei un impegno che
ne sto gioco faccio record del mondo io
lo dico però non mi impegno beh pensavo
peggio dai 11 laszlo a lei
lei se il lancio di lato riesco a farlo
meglio non so perché parli da porco
demonio saper no no no no uno l'ho
buttato per terra che sfiga per uno
buono ancora uno non ho avuto piccola
casa dai cavolo veloce voci corri premio
l'ho preso vale vale vale ce l'ho fatta
quanto fatto
minchia record mondiale 2 10750 come ha
fatto c'è veramente impostato fatto io
5.700 di schifo ci sono ancora
classifica mondiale
c'è molto italiano maledizione nesso
ecco in italia nessuno sa consegnare i
pacchi allora bravi a consegnare i
pacchi ci sono gli americani
i coreani un croato tedesco polacchi a
molto bravi e consegnare i party
polacchi polacchi pacchi no signori non
so se ve lo ricordate ma io sì play
ovviamente questo gioco dove devi
saltare tra un camion all'altro e
schivare gli ostacoli e arrivare alla
fine è fighissimo di fare passi dagli
stessi creatori di super off però non ne
sono sicuro di arrivare alla fine del
vallone fighissima se non fosse che che
sono scarso come la morte però vuole un
altro discorso
mamma mia che casino aiutano amici dove
sta andando
em up e buyers che mira brutta che ciò è
difficilissimo story vere 9 devo farlo
tutto questo ma parco demonio morto ieri
incastrato nel duomo
rimango fermo guarda
noi non siamo in porta avanti lui l'ex
baby è il primo gol è andata 5 di uno
perché tutti gli altri avevo fatto in un
altro lido andatevelo a cercare classe
al tranquillissimo
ma il doppio salto non è che sia così
titola porca vacca let's go invece è
carino next level doppio santomieri
tombotto allora l'altro scusami non era
pino herisau tratti quindi si fregiano
tutti fighissimo che si sono tutti va
bene mi piace come gusta allora va bene
così vai vai vai privati a è fighissimo
sto gioco non me lo ricordavo così figo
aiutano però imminente sono ancora come
come è possibile non sono caduto fermi
zitti
no no no mi han no porca vacca non ero
caduto era fichissima sta cosa con
ragazzi anche questo potrebbe essere
considerato come amazon corriere
simulator x carità mi sembra mi sembra
molto reale che ogni tanto vedo dei
camion fa la stessa cosa ora cavalca se
la fanno ma sono delle cose che escono
dal terreno
non è un po troppo
madonna un camion in bocca ma perché
sono capaci apprezzarli sono nel punto
sbagliato che è piano piano piano va
sano e va lontano
se vediamo maisano e vai un bye sano e
va lontano
ora che la frittata è questo livello
ragazzi tra tutti è veramente difficile
che certo è veramente difficilissimo ce
la fai a centrare un camion di questi
era difficile anche prima scusami
sono adesso bene e sto bene sto bene un
po di tachipirina e passa tutto
benissimo
stavo per toccare terra prima di toccare
il traguardo ma va bene così bene gli
sia piaciuto ragazzi questi skydeck noi
ci vediamo al seguito
[Musica]